when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me
hi my name is sydney welcome back to
hell and as per usual before we launch
in today's video is sponsored by
established titles which you'd better
watch because i tried really hard
now the other day i was researching for
another topic another video that is
still on the way do not worry those of
you who think i am not making long-form
content anymore i am and during my
adventure on the internet i came across
an article about she-hulk and a
particular part of this article
set my blood on fire it explains that
while marvel films lack humanistic
character traits such as sex despite
iron man being a womanizing millionaire
and thor being a god surrounded by a sea
of women these male superheroes don't
pay these ladies any mind because the
world is in danger and that is
understandably more important however
the primary she-hulk writer wants to
change that narrative this isn't all
just about boys and their need to feel
worthy now jennifer walters she-hulk has
arrived and she wants nothing to do with
saving the world she's ready to be
honest about her life with her newfound
powers juggling her career and her
dating life is there anything more
depressing than dating in your 30s
what else you gonna do as a hulk uh
return to my career that i have spent
years building
ah
what the so the male superheroes
don't have any time for women because
they're busy saving the world but the
female superhero is not interested in
saving the world and is instead
interested only in her career
and dating life do you see
do you see the problem you could be an
avenger oh i'm not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans who still save the
world
unlike you my friend it's like writers
want people to hate female leads whether
you've seen it or not you're probably
all aware at this stage that she-hulk is
yet another bizarre attempt to shove
corporate feminism down everybody's
throats despite what feminist hollywood
might have you believe these films shows
and franchises are not appealing to men
but they're also not appealing to women
seriously i don't know a single woman
who actually enjoys this except maybe
the bitter ones with like 15 cats who's
to say um i don't own a single cat and i
enjoy it yet
don't have any cats yet so that's what i
want to talk about today why feminist
hollywood movies are uniquely terrible
why they don't appeal to anyone
especially women and all the components
that go into making them so deeply
unwatchable but before you once again
bored my hell gondola and we snuggle up
together to watch some marvel movie
punishment let's hear from today's
sponsor established titles did you see
this
see what this article it says that they
cut down like millions of trees in
scotland to make room for windmills
i hate windmills wind turbines whatever
same thing there comes a point in every
person's life where they have to pay
homage to scotland and their scottish
roots you still don't have scottish
roots where they must go to establish
titles to become a lord or lady get
their own fancy certificate and a square
foot of land on a private scottish
estate what is happening but more
importantly because established titles
promises to plant a tree for every order
place because we cannot let the english
windmills turbines win it does not
matter that you can call yourself a
laird or lady on your plane tickets your
dating profiles and your credit cards it
matters that way lords and ladies will
save the trees
for scotland and for freedom
you guys know the drill i defiled my
face for you head over to established
titles or click the link in the
description to take advantage of their
awesome labor day sale the next 200
people to use my link to buy a title
pack will effectively have their plot of
land next to my plot of land like a
little kingdom and don't forget to use
code sydney for 10 off your entire
purchase
if we take a trip back to the 80s and
90s i think that it is fair to argue
this was a great time for film and
entertainment story lines feel authentic
the characters are memorable and the
writing is still so quotable today and
most importantly writers weren't focused
on forced diversity or writing films
with the sole purpose of pushing
woochism and other social narratives
good films did well we didn't
pathologize when they didn't and during
this time period plenty of great films
and shows with female leads captured
people's attention terminator with sarah
connor ellen ripley and aliens princess
leia and star wars there are tons of
these tons of these examples some of
which you won't agree with but i
personally enjoy lilu from the fifth
element because i don't know i like that
she's feminine and emotional while also
being like this weird light creature who
will save the planet and let's be real
we all collectively enjoyed her bandage
outfit you aren't lying to me
you're lying to yourself but these
female leads are a far cry from what
feminist hollywood is giving us today in
an effort to place women in what have
been long considered male roles feminist
hollywood over-corrected giving us a
series of unlikable unrelatable
unrealistic strong female leads i need
you to fix his suit the suit is literal
perfection it will be
when it fits a woman
it's a no
that's gonna be a no for me okay thank
you for your input walmart robin the
trouble is they've done this over and
over and over and have clearly learned
nothing the box office doesn't lie
even if screen rant does now the most
obvious starting point for this entire
discussion is that these modern feminist
films fail
because of sexism one article i found
thinks that captain marvel was
criticized because men are man babies
who don't want to see a woman headlining
a marvel movie in reality brie larson is
just like super unlikable on and off
screen and if the objective was to
embody an effortlessly badass woman that
men love and women want to be well that
wasn't achieved whatsoever i have
nothing to prove to you i do all my
stunts i did i did my stunts because i
thought that that's what everyone did
[Music]
tom cruise over here no it won't be the
first me not the next tom cruise thank
you very much
for the record this is tom cruise doing
his own stunts what leftists and
feminists often attribute to sexism
could be more accurately summarized by
the fact that film and tv today just
isn't really all that good and having
female leads doesn't change that if
anything with the way most of them are
written it makes it worse and there are
a few reasons for this for starters most
of these characters are female for the
sake of it when they're gender swapped
in well-known series and franchises the
truth is there isn't any actual need for
them think star wars or the female
doctor who you see i care so little
about these female leads i can't even
remember their names girl with shiny
light stick who has a disappointing
romance arc blonde female character
absolutely no one asked for on a serious
note you guys do not understand how much
i hated rey in star wars i watched it
the whole time thinking
i don't mind if they kill the main
character this time i don't mind i'll
i'll i will i will do it i will
i will i me i i volunteers tribute and
because these female characters are
often shoved into a movie or a show for
no good reason it means that they aren't
fully fledged people with their own pain
struggles and flaws they are there for
the express purpose of propagating a
feminist message and when they do for
some reason have a struggle it's as
one-dimensional and flat as this well
here's the thing bruce i'm great at
controlling my anger i do it all the
time
when i'm catcalled in the street when
incompetent men explain my own area of
expertise to me i do it
pretty much every day because if i don't
i will get called
emotional or difficult or
might just literally get murdered so i'm
an expert at controlling my anger
because i do it infinitely more than you
bruce banner turns into the hulk because
he has inner turmoil that he sometimes
can't control i read that some changes
to his backstory have added that he was
abused as a child and that he and hulk
are two separate personas struggling for
control of the body
when i had the gauntlet the stones i
really tried to bring her back the point
is unlike she-hulk banner is not dealing
with some trivial nonsense
where someone calls out to him in the
street to say he looks nice and i have
to admit even while i was collecting and
watching clips to edit together this
video the way that banner is portrayed
on screen especially his relationship
with black widow the way that she calms
him down and so on it even was starting
to get me in the feels she hulk elicits
none of that when i watch her rather
than finding her humorous which i don't
know maybe that's that maybe that's what
she's supposed to be i just find her
annoying and weak which is ironic
considering she's supposed to be a
strong female character your
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing given that i am a woman i
do feel a little qualified to say that i
am acutely aware of the unique struggles
that women have however articulating
them like this is just so
dizziness the female protagonists of old
including those who were featured in
older films that have now been remade
and destroyed were women who embodied
actual feminine and female
characteristics and traits but the
difference is that those traits didn't
stop them from being badasses and they
aren't female for the sake of a female
character they are well-written
thoughtful representations of a
character who just happens to be female
take sarah connor for example in
terminator 2 she is hell-bent on killing
mike dyson a man she doesn't know for
something he doesn't know will have
terrible consequences when she finally
has the chance and sees his son trying
to protect him she breaks down her own
son shows up and they share a moment our
badass leading lady suddenly becomes a
human and a mother it is no different at
the end of the fifth element when lilu
knows the earth is about to be exploded
her very purpose is to save life and she
can't fulfill that purpose because she
can't see why humanity is worth saving
if all it does is kill and destroy that
and you know she got like shot at and
then beaten up and she's she's bleeding
it's all very sad the scene where bruce
willis is holding her and she's crying
tells us how big a burden this is for
her today's female characters are flat
and empty and impossible to relate to
they have no flaws they immediately
succeed at everything they do and they
have no journey of personal growth and
development we see this when she-hulk
beats banner repeatedly during training
together we see this when rey in star
wars immediately masters things that
took luke forever to learn like stop
this milan is a gifted fighter from day
one which is a hundred percent the
opposite of what she is in the animation
and apparently captain marvel is the
strongest of all the superheroes because
okay i believe you think i'm jealous is
that what i'm feeling
to cap it off so many of these women are
either full of unnecessary unkind caddy
lines and whining or they're in a
pigment pickle measuring
or they're in a manned pickle measuring
contest with the men around them some of
you might disagree with me here but one
of the reasons i loved wonder woman was
because she embodied a femininity often
lost on female superheroes she trained
for years to hone her skills to earn her
skills and when these skills failed her
and a loved one dies her pain is so
obviously crushing it makes her
relatable and when she finally triumphs
we celebrate along with her that and you
know the movie made me walk out of the
cinema wanting to become a ninja i'm
also talking about the 2017 wonder woman
movie and not the weird garbage that
came after the point is a well-rounded
character regardless of sex makes a film
worth watching but throwing a woman in
there just for the sake of it isn't a
good enough reason for me to care
especially when their entire personality
is built around i don't know like
fighting the patriarchy or something and
this brings us to the point that modern
feminist characters are not people they
serve as vessels for feminist propaganda
and man-hating i think it's more or less
true that when writers focus more
attention on the sex skin color or
sexual orientation of a character rather
than making that character into a
multi-faceted individual it's ultimately
unwatchable batwoman which was cancelled
after three seasons stank to high heaven
of identity politics it started off with
endlessly snarky comments and devolved
from there an article from earlier this
year wrote that it was groundbreaking to
have a black bisexual actress become
batwoman but even this article notes
that the casting choice didn't do much
to mitigate the narrative problems of
the show because newsflash being gay and
female doesn't change terrible writing
sorry about that while we have no idea
why batgirl was cancelled before it even
aired something tells me it probably had
something to do with the same identity
politics that killed off so many of its
predecessors overall writers who don't
properly flesh out a character do that
character zero favors worse still are
the female characters who are forced to
compete with their male counterparts or
who are made superior to them even if it
doesn't make any sense people came down
pretty hard on thor love and thunder
which features natalie portman as the
female thor or jane because it didn't
make jane's character look awesome it
just made thor's character look like an
imbecile as some of you may have noticed
this is actually a very common theme in
modern television and film men are often
portrayed as weak silly and misogynistic
just make sure to put the eggs on top
so i shouldn't open up the carton and
just dump them all in there
okay
i'm gonna go wait in the car
just trying to help yeah i know how to
pack my own suitcase i can pack my own
grocery bag let's also remember that men
make up a huge portion of audiences when
it comes to watching particularly
superhero movies and all this does is
alienate that base these films go out of
their way to make men look bad and it's
different to simply portraying men as
the villain in addition to that men can
never seem to be of any help to the
women they fight or work alongside i
personally hate this because it makes it
a matter of male versus female rather
than how can we solve this problem
together i mean it also leads to weird
situations where we are forced to
suspend our disbelief to watch some tiny
woman beat the snot out of a man twice
her size because again yeah i believe
you can throw around this man lesbian
bella one thing i also think is worth
noting is that every good female
character i've listed so far has
emotions and has emotional motivations
for doing the things that they do
unfortunately today's female leads have
these feelings and emotions written out
of them and if they do for whatever
reason have a feeling it's often totally
ridiculous and over the top i don't
think that captain marvel experiences a
single feeling while on screen even when
she's alone and supposed to be
reflective
sorry bri this isn't an emotional face
try harder can you keep your emotions in
check long enough to take me on just
kidding she doesn't have any on the flip
side you have she hulk flipping out at
men outside a bar for being weirdos
because she's sick of men i don't know i
i don't know what i'm supposed to get
from this if rendering female characters
emotionless robot people is supposed to
make them appear stronger and push
against this idea that women are more
emotional than men
it's an abject failure a strong woman
knows when to be emotional and when to
put her feelings aside it isn't some sad
reflection of women that we experience
emotions and it shouldn't be forcibly
removed from these female personalities
in order for them to achieve something
worthwhile and you know if they wanted
to have she-hulk losing her absolute
chops at some men it would have made a
lot more sense if she wasn't presented
to us as a character who consistently
gets her way until this point it's not
like we've seen her having setback after
setback and getting angrier and angrier
so this moment makes absolutely no sense
not that anything she does makes sense
taking all the traits that are often
seen in villainous male characters and
just shoving them onto female characters
doesn't suddenly mean we're going to
like them i think the fact of the matter
is that showrunners and writers
contribute sexism to their own
characters by writing them poorly and no
amount of shaming from directors and
writers is going to change that my real
plea
is for men to have enough empathy to go
see movies starring women
stop this obviously there are a couple
points that i left out of this video in
the interest of not having it be a
thousand years long but in summary good
female protagonists are not
one-dimensional they aren't simply there
to parrot liberal feminist talking
points they serve a higher purpose and
often have deep rooted motivations for
what they do they don't compete with
their male counterparts rather they
acknowledge the strengths of the men
around them even sometimes acquiescing
to them when necessary and needed i am a
woman who really does enjoy female leads
not because i can relate to them 100 of
the time but because i like going on a
journey with them that leads them to be
stronger and more resilient or going in
the opposite direction where they're a
little more hardened and learned to be
softer and to love and so forth i don't
need to be bludgeoned to death with a
feminist message to watch these movies
but i also don't want to be subjected to
ridiculous feminist propaganda that has
no place in modern society watching
female characters stand up at the
expense of their male counterparts in
the end wochism has become a shield for
bad television and film sexism has
become the justification when a
female-led film doesn't do well as if
male lead films don't fail all the time
and these justifications fall flat when
you consider just how little effort is
put into these female-led films and the
female characters who lead them feminist
hollywood sucks and i'm fairly certain
that they have absolutely nobody to
blame but themselves now before i open
the floor to all of you this is just a
reminder to check out established titles
using the link in the description when
you do and you use code sydney you'll
get 10 off any purchase now open the
floor to all of you what do you all
think is this as annoying as i think it
is do you like female characters do you
dislike female characters does it put
you off watching a movie if it has a
female lead what do you make of gender
swapping is it good is it bad is it
unnecessary is it very necessary what do
you think of she-hulk and the blow-up
around she-hulk or the opinions around
she-hulk and what do you generally make
of this issue overall as always if you
like the video hit subscribe and the
thumbs up button if you want to leave a
comment video so just be respectful
about it and i will see you guys next
time